- As long as prosthesis have been around,
people have been really focusing
on making it look like a
hand and move like a hand,
but a hand is not just a grabber.
A hand is a touch.
It's touch that engages
you with the world.
It's touch that engages you with people.
A prosthesis without touch is a tool.
By giving touch, we're giving back a hand.
- I worked in a factory
setting before I lost my arm.
I was doing some cleaning
out from underneath
a shredder-type machine,
and it grabbed the material
that was in my hand and pulled
my hand into the machine.
I didn't think that I'd ever
have the sensation of touch
or anything back again,
and then my prosthetist told me about the
research program up here in Cleveland.
They hope to be able to
give me the sense of touch.
- The research that we've been doing
is reconnecting the man to the machine.
Basically, learning how to
take what the prosthesis feels
and translates so that the
person using it feels it.
For the brain to feel touch
as being their actual hand,
it's really important that
we activate or stimulate the
wires that the brain always
used to get from the hand.
What we do is we implant cuff
electrodes and then we apply
really tiny amounts of current
that activate those wires,
and that information
then goes to the brain.
So we've been learning how
to place this information
on that nerve, so the
brain thinks it's his hand.
They can feel not just
buzzing, but also a touch,
a pressure, like somebody
putting a finger on their hand.
And in fact, we've been
able to see that intensity
of the artificial stimulation
mimics the intact hand.
- Soft big block.
The first time they put
sensation on and everything,
it was just incredible.
It was like, "Wow."
Could actually feel an area
in my hand, a certain area,
tingling, and vibrations, and stuff.
Small soft block.
I said, just an incredible feeling.
Bringing the prosthetic home
with the sensory hand on it
and being able to feel and everything's
changed life considerably.
It's just little things that
people take for granted.
Brushing teeth, to be able
to hold the toothpaste
and be able to squeeze and
tell how hard I'm squeezing it
so I don't squeeze it
and it go everyplace.
It makes it a lot easier.
- We're at the point where
subjects can use their prosthesis
at home, and they can have
sensation while they're at home.
It makes them two-handed again.
It brings back their
hand, it makes them whole.